chers amis
les temps sont durs bien que vous arrive
t métiers distincts vous avez l'air bien
fatigué oh non non mon cher ni ni
fatigué ni malade non c'est pire que
cela encore
je m'ennuie et cet affreux l'ennui c'est
parce que vous n'avez pas l'imagination
moi je ne m'ennuie jamais je sais cher
mais je devrai réagir
moi je me soucie seul bon alors là vous
exagérez
je suis là moi et puis vous n'avez qu'à
aller voir françois ou quasiment jamais
je ne voulais pas vous perdre deux
peines seulement mais les relations
mondaines ne sont plus venus me voir
dans l'île depuis si longtemps plus nous
mêmes nous nous installons dans la
routine
aucun événement ne vient briser notre
vie quotidienne
aventures de renouveau et de fait on
fait ça pour cela vous avez raison
monsieur du noble c'est dommage mais il
ya très longtemps que nous n'avons pas
eu de fait dans l'île aux hérons
souvenez vous la dernière c'était le
concours de chicoutimi chaque fois
refusées mais trouver une idée de fête
vous
c'est exact ma chère amie il faut que
nous fassions une fête donc moi fulbert
en scène death note en tant que
président de la fête de nos enfants je
décide d'organiser aujourd'hui même une
fête
jacques ne pas avoir un stand où une
muse en toute petite participation donc
vous avertit le facteur pour quelques le
port la nouvelle à nos amis we make me
suis dit aujourd'hui c'est trop tôt les
délais sont trop courts vous n'y pensez
pas non mais moi je te ra mais voyons
nous sommes tous capables
d'improvisation non enfin je compte sur
vous un bon je vais bientôt tous mes
amis est ce que j'ai bien le numéro de
téléphone de françois oui au total eur 1
une grande fête aujourd'hui il est fou
il faut que je trouve unité
vie j'ai une idée une idée magnifique
même
oui mais il faut que je trouve un
costume et un stand alors je vous laisse
avec touba rendez vous êtes tout à
l'heure à la grande fête
vient fourmies 2 18 m
avec un chapeau sur la tête
sans n'existe prends
ça n'existe pas
une fourmi
traînant un char
l'un deux pingouins paix et de canards
ça n'existe pas
une fourmi parlant français
parlent en latin
javanais
ça n'existe pas
et pourquoi pas
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
à
vous lire indique tout le passé le
présent fait même à venir venez
consulter boule de cristal noir au bois
chez middle orangeade du les blessés on
y voit du grand habit neuf fois que j'ai
approché liquide
grands fauves du monde dressé par un
chanteur de temps venez assister au
numéro prodigieux des puces les plus
dociles du monde pour approcher tireurs
d'élite avec trois balles trois ans
seulement détruisez la grande pyramide
tenait tous vous exercez aux meilleurs
jeunes adresse l'histoire alors
que l'ambiance mes amis mais quelle
ambiance c'est formidable je vais faire
le tour de tous les stands mais
auparavant je vais aller me faire
prédire mon avenir pour savoir si je
vais gagner au jeu
madame giulia pourriez vous me parler de
mon avenir s'il vous plaît mais bien sûr
monsieur quasi mieux que voulez-vous
savoir eh bien je voudrais savoir si je
vais gagner au jeu de françois et simon
numéro sera réussi
[Musique]
je vois que vous êtes doué de qualités
exceptionnelles
absolument oui cela on ne peut pas venir
que vous avez beaucoup d'amis qui vous
aime ah bon et notamment un être
houle avec de grandes oreilles
qui vit dans une malle et qui est très
très proche de vous ce alors je me
demande qui ça peut être je crois que je
vous ai tout dit monsieur casino armés
mais non je vous en prie continuez s'il
vous plaît
lui dois vous dire monsieur casimir veut
tout dire bon ben vous avez oublié des
choses très importantes
vous avez oublié de dire que je suis bon
un intelligent généreux que j'ai un
grand sens artistique quand je suis
courageux que j'ai un caractère
extraordinaire que je suis modeste à
face à saisir tu exagère quand on dit la
bonne aventure on ne peut pas dire que
des compliments ne m'aimait pas du tout
au contraire au bon sens et au revoir
après tout ce qu'il a peut-être raison
je vois mes chers amis que vous avez une
dispute avec casimir aussi je vous aux
france vers ostende de notre bon et 1000
en plus abel sont dans leur boîte ah bon
il n'ya que cette série c'est bien
françois cazis mais revenez gens fous de
tournée générale avec plaisir
d'après voici rennes entre on l a fait
casimir voilà bah casimir choix alors tu
n'as pas de stand pas de spectacle a
pour sûr tu le dunk mais attendez mes
amis j'attends simplement que l'ambiance
tombe à point pour que vous soyez
attentif à mon numéro je suis le metteur
en scène de ce spectacle grandiose comme
et deux assistants on vous présentait
mesdames et messieurs pleins feux sur la
vedette je vous présente le célèbre
fakir les nord
mesdames mesdemoiselles messieurs mes
hommages pour commencer ayez la bonté de
remarquer que notre célèbre maître est
assis sur des clous
je suis ainsi des clous
il peut aussi sortir un lapin de son
chapeau
je peux sortir un lapin de mon chapeau
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
ils peuvent aussi sortir des quantités
de bons foulard de couleur
quantité de bons fous là
ah
il pour continuer mesdames et messieurs
je vais vous demander la plus grande
attention
pour cet exercice notre grand maître a
besoin de la plus grande concentration
aussi je vais vous demander le plus
grand silence
silence sur
la bonté de fermer les yeux pour aider
monsieur léonard milieu fermé les yeux
monsieur 10 nov eh bien merci les
réseaux si gély très bien france soir
[Applaudissements]
mesdames et messieurs
vous pouvez ouvrir aux yeux
votre concentration
associé à la mienne mon permis un tour
de force
j'ai devant moi un certain nombre
d'objets d'origine de provenance
inconnue
pourriez vous m'aider à trouver leurs
noms
qu'est ce que c'est que ce si c'est cela
pour se montrer votre cerveau c'est bien
un porte-monnaie monsieur d'islande il
est même je crois assez bien garni oh
oui
oh et ça qu'est ce que je sais c'est
beaucoup mais effectivement on sait très
bien un collier très bien gardons le en
vie sont en ravissant et ceci en fin
d'année cet étrange objet c'est une
autre
mais ma moto ou
c'est une montre au blizzard
effectivement c'est une montre pour
remercier mademoiselle futé de son
précieux collaboration je lui offre
cette montre je n'en porte jamais
ah ah